well collaboration sounds wonderful and
in a perfect world all parties would
come to the table with healthy
self-esteem and a willingness to
collaborate but we know that in real
life that doesn't usually happen so
let's say there's a writer sensitive
maybe a loner by Nature has to deal with
a director that's a little more dominant
and the process is not so collaborative
what would you tell that screenwriter to
keep themselves and the project still
intact you want to start yeah one
suggestion I would make because I do
this all the time when I'm working with
clients or when I'm in a situation where
a script is being developed and all of
those people are in the room together
and that is when someone confronts you
with an idea or an objection to
something you've written don't defend
and don't try and argue it ask questions
questions are a very powerful tool in
any aspect of collaboration I think but
what you want to say to the director is
oh so when did you start feeling this
way or how do you see this character or
what made you say that or try and get
underneath the suggestion or the
boneheaded comment because whatever
they're saying the truth of it is they
had a negative emotional reaction to
something in your script and if they did
somebody else might so what you want to
get at is what was the core cause of
that and attack that and work that and
then suggest something that you think
might accommodate their concern but is
different than what's already in the
script I don't think any good director
some bad director's perhaps but when
I've been in those situations nobody
wants a writer who's going to be just a
powder puff and cave at everything but
they don't want them to just dig in
their heels and say no it's my way or
the highway they want someone who's
going to be open to anything they say
maybe not agree with the specific
solution of the problem but jump in and
say okay what can we do about this
together and I think questions we'll get
to that that's good I like that from my
because I work mostly with director
and directors run into a lot of
obstacles which can be producers or
writers or our actors and when I say the
obstacle is the resistance because
you're talking about when someone has
resistance or is not available my first
thing is a little different than
Michaels how they're going along the
same lines in a way is realize that any
resistance usually comes out of fear
there's a fear of something and just be
sensitive don't try to attack it don't
try to what you know don't don't be the
psychologist and try to deal with but
realize that that resistance if you have
an actor who's resisting or a
writer-director working in the writer
and the rice says no I can't do it I
can't do that doesn't mean they can't do
it there's some fear going on fear that
maybe you can't do it well fear that
it's going to destroy the film or
whatever and there's love there's a lot
of resistance and then assayed to
directors who are working with writers
if you have a point of disagreement and
say about a scene and what the scene is
about or whether if the scene it belongs
if you stay on the point of disagreement
this is similar to it i think is michael
saying you have a problem because
somebody has to win and somebody has to
lose and you've got a real problem you
know let's say it's a discussion whether
or not we even need this particular
scene my suggestion to the directors is
go back to a point of agreement which
means get away from the point of
disagreement get away from the argument
about this scene or this character or
this moment go back to something that's
more general ok we agree that in this
part of the journey this is what the
character is going through this is where
yes ok and then move from a point of
agreement towards the point of
disagreement to find out where it starts
to fall apart and you may find out it's
not that scene that's the problem it was
something before that you're both
feeling in other words get out of the
argument and get into a point of
agreement and start to move towards the
problem area
you